[Musique]
bonsoir christan kabylo merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france procès
donc reporté un par décision du juge
pourtant tout avait l'air a priori
d'être prêts notamment au niveau de la
sécurité parce que c'est important dans
ce type de procès pourquoi ce retard
selon vous il semblerait que les avocats
de derek chemin est fait appel jeter des
coups de culpabilité mais ce qui est
tout à fait normal et ce qu'ils avaient
tout à fait le droit de faire ça va être
juste un petit retard la porte est de 24
heures et la sélection du jury commencée
d2 après ça on va s'attendre très
certainement à quatre semaines de
sélection un process de sélection du
jury et le procès en lui-même ne devrait
pas commencer avant le 29 mars
alors justement la sélection des jurés
un casse tête on imagine dans ce type de
procès très médiatisé très politisé même
tout à fait lorsqu'il faut savoir aux
etats unis c'est que tous les citoyens
américains majeurs peuvent être appelés
à la cour pour être nombre de 2 2
l'inter jury dans toutes les affaires
pénales et donc pour cette affaire
précise le cas de georges claude il
qu'il soit tout à fait impartial et ça
va être très difficile car c'est quand
même une affaire de ton qu'on avait tous
les détails se dérouler sous nos yeux et
ont tout le monde est au courant donc
depuis quelques semaines l'état
2 du minnesota on voit des
questionnaires à des potentiels jurés
donc ces questionnaires font à peu près
16 à 17 pages on leur demande absolument
toute leur vie est ce qu'ils ont été
impactés par les émeutes
connaissait-il georges claude et sa
famille quel genre de média quel genre
de podcasts quatre genres de livres ils
lisent pour afin de d'essayer de
déterminer finalement leur position sur
sur le spectre politique
comment être neutre justement devant ce
type de procès commence justement ne pas
faire un procès avant l'heure en sachant
tous deux de ses jurés alors c'est tout
à fait impossible il y tout à fait
impossible d'être complètement impartial
dans ce procès car c'est un procès qui
était tout à fait médiatique et qu'on a
vu se dérouler sous nos yeux
quand on a vu les éléments du procès se
déroule sous nos yeux durant les
derniers mois
par contre ce que les gêner et les
sélectionneurs du jury vont de
reconnaître si ça n'est pas ça n'est pas
de sélectionner des gens qui vont être
impartiaux mais des gens qui vont
pouvoir décider en dépit de leur billet
d'abord un jugement impartial donc ils
savent très bien le sélectionneur ça va
tenues manque personne va être
complètement impartial
durant ce jeu se ce procès mais il faut
que les gens aient conscience de leurs
billets alors derek sherwin en tout cas
lui risquait la prison à perpétuité
son procès en plein mouvement blake
lively matters pourrait-il on imagine
servir d'exemple il est compliqué de
rendre justice
sereinement encore une fois dans ce type
d'affaires très très politique parce que
tout le monde l'attend ce procès aux
états unis avec des émeutes que
évidemment cela a provoqué oui parce que
c'est en fait un procès qui est tout à
fait historique et c'est un procès qui
est historique pour trois raisons
d'abord il ya la figure de georges
claude tout à fait symbolique on a vu et
on le voit sur vos écrans ce moment
c'est quelqu'un qui a vraiment été une
cause ralliant
tain de tous de tous les cris pour tout
les rassemblements pour contre les
violences policières partout dans le
monde sauf si le premier procès le
premier procès pour violences policières
de l'herbe idle et on sait bien que peut
pas être admis au centre de son le
combat pour la justice et pour l'égalité
raciale
et puis enfin et je pensais ce qu'il ya
de plus important ici c'est que celle
que le premier procès post 6 janvier le
6 janvier on a vu des militants pour la
plupart blanc qui ont pu comme ça
prendre le capitole sans que sans qu'ils
ne soient inquiétés par la police mais
de l'autre côté on a ce giorgio floyd
donc on ne sait pas très bien de quoi il
était coupable qui a été qui a été tué
par un policier et donc là comme vous
l'avez dit très bien
c'est vraiment un pays qui est à bout de
souffle qui est vraiment divisé et on
peut s'attendre durant ce procès
vraiment à de nombreuses manifestations
et quelle que soit l'issue même du
procès certainement à des émeutes
oui j'ai cédé ma prochaine question il
va falloir faire très attention à
l'issue de ce procès aux peines
prononcées au risque de provoquer ces
nouvelles émeutes
il va falloir apaisé ça va être très
difficile pour les juges
oui c'est très difficile pour les jeux
ça va être très difficile pour pour le
président biden et l'on voit là que même
avant que le procès ne démarre il y à
déjà en fait des manifestations des
protestations il va sans dire il est
absolument que s'il ya un lieu si derek
chauvine n'est pas jugée coupable qu'il
y aura des émeutes d'une ampleur peut
être catastrophique dans le pays puisque
on sait déjà ce sont ces la mort de
georges dooghe qui a généré ces émeutes
au mois de mai on peut attendre à une
issue du procès qui a eu lieu en plus
juste un an après la mort de georges lot
donc la date anniversaire
ce qui ferait qu'amplifier un non lieu
ou une non culpabilité de derek sherwin
vous avez parlé effectivement de joe
biden qui entrent en piste la police on
le rappelle a toujours été défendu
farouchement par donald trump le fait
que ce procès s'ouvre sous l'herbe
hayden est ce que ça peut changer
quelque chose
by dell n'avait pas vraiment un discours
tout à fait différent de donald trump a
on se rappelle des méthodes kenosha
durant la campagne ou lui aussi appelé à
l'ol de la loi et l'ordre tout comme
trump l'avait fait par contre l'as et
j'ai envie de dire le premier test de
l'administration by donner cet
instrument important c'est comme je le
rappelais précédemment joe biden a mis
la justice raciale et la justice sociale
au centre de cette plateforme
et s'il ya un non lieu ou une
culpabilité de derrick chauvine ça sera
vraiment un coup assez sec durant les
premières semaines de son administration
merci à tristan cabello maître de
conférences en civilisation américaine à
l'université johns hopkins